you did a lot of stamina because we have
three tops without a break because I
thought it's better to you know get done
and if we can go to the airport wherever
you need to go and then the workshop
ends okay so say 45 minutes more okay
and today we get the second talk of
Sohail which I'm very much looking
forward to after the exciting first
talking thank you thanks Monica
um good morning everybody
um yeah so this is the second part of my
talk I'll continue to talk about uh
recent progress on sublinear time
algorithms for maximum matching
um and what I'll be talking about today
is
um based on joint works with Mohammad
alrani who's sitting here and Avia drop
insane
um
so
um in the first part of the talk I
talked about Sabine algorithm more on
the algorithmic side
um and I talked especially about how
sublinger algorithms have helped design
much faster Dynamic algorithms for
maximum matching
um which is basically why I decided to
talk about sublinear algorithms in this
Workshop
um today I'll only talk about lower
bounds um there have been some exciting
developments on proving the lower
balance for this problem uh that I'm
trying to that I'm planning to cover
today okay if you missed the first talk
it's completely okay I'll give all the
needed definitions
um or if you attended the first talk and
forgot about everything it's okay
um okay so I'll start by defining the
problem which which is the maximum
matching problem
um and matching is a collection of
vertex disjoint edges
um and we want to matching that's as
large as possible
um
that would be the maximum matching
problem an approximate matching is a
matching that's approximately as large
as the maximum
has numerous applications I won't talk
about them
and
okay so when we talk about sublinear
algorithms we want to specify how we can
access the input it's very important how
the input is represented if we only want
to see a small fraction of the input on
this side on the output
um two models are common adjacent to the
lists and adjacency Matrix
um
and yeah this is list you can query you
specify vertex an index in the list and
in return you get the ID of that
neighbor adjacency Matrix you specify
two vertices and you're given if they
are adjacent or not
okay trivial bounds you can query
everything here it takes order M queries
and you can solve it using your favorite
um linear time approximate matching
algorithm
um in the adjacent matrix model you can
query every entry and it takes n Square
time
oh and throughout the talk and we'll
denote the number of vertices I'm going
to denote the number of edges
um
yeah so I mentioned this also in the
first talk um these trivial bounds are
actually optimal if you want to find the
edge set of the matching and even if
it's just an approximate matching with
very bad constant approximation
um so kind of the the right question in
a sense for sublinear time algorithms is
can we estimate the size of the maximum
matching instead of reporting all of its
edges
and today I'll specifically focus on
adjacency lists um this is
um
the setting we will prove the lower
bounds in in other words we will say
that any algorithm for example providing
an alpha approximation has to query this
amount of entries of the of the
adjacency lists
okay
um any questions about the model
okay okay
um so
I just uh quickly want to again repeat
what algorithms are known I mentioned
this in the first talk as well but just
to give you a sense in in case you
missed the first talk
uh so basically
um what we know right now after a long
line of work uh as these three
algorithms
um one can get a half approximation this
is the approximation this is the running
time one can get a half approximation in
order and time and poly login time
hiding all polyglock factors
so one can get half approximation of the
size of Maximum matching in order and
time you can get slightly better than
half and slightly worse than end time
um and
um
this was a joint work with
aviad Muhammad and I mean
um and in a nice result this past Fox
um Cheyenne Peter and fashion pong
showed that you can get in sub quadratic
time about myself approximation
all right
so this is the the the set of affairs
with this problem on the algorithmic
side and today we will talk about lower
bounds okay
and just um I wanted to quickly talk
about the motivation via Dynamic
matching so basically in the dynamic
matching problem you want to maintain
um
a large matching or an approximation to
the size of the matching
as the graph changes so there's been a
whole series of
um trade-offs for this problem
um which seemed a bit tricky to improve
upon but since last year there have been
a lot of improvements over these
um and all of these blue improvements
basically use sub-linear algorithms
um but one crucial difference that these
blue results all only maintain the size
of the matching where's the previous
bounds
algorithms for maximum matching have a
lot of implications in the dynamic
setting so you want to study sublinger
time algorithms and also you want to
study what they cannot do so that's why
we'll talk about lower bounds today
so I start by
um
talking again about the lower bound
construction of Panasonic probably in a
little bit more detail because we'll
also use some of the ideas in the in the
new lower bounds
so um so what is the partners it says
that if one wants to provide any
constant approximation of the size of
the matching
um even if the matching is guaranteed to
be of size linear in n one has to spend
Omega n time
one has to query Omega n entries of the
adjacency lists
um and the the construction is is as
follows so we have Epsilon and dummy
vertices so this is the yes case this is
the no case we're going to have to
distinguish them if we want to provide a
constant approximation
so in both types of graphs we'll have
Epsilon and dummy vertices
and we will also have dummy versus in
our construction so it's important to
know what role they are playing so these
Epsilon and dummy viruses because
they're only Epsilon n of them they're
not going to change the size of the
matching by match by more than Epsilon n
right but on the other hand they can
have Epsilon N squared edges adjacent to
them so they make the graph super dense
and at the same time don't really change
the size of the matching
okay and then we have a core
um connected to the to these dummy
vertices so the core in one case
includes a perfect matching the the red
matching
and the chord in the second case
um
does not have a large matching right so
so in this graph the matching is very
small has size Epsilon n you can only
match the dummy vertices here you're
gonna have a large matching and if you
want to provide the constant
approximation constant better than
Epsilon you're going to have to
distinguish these two and why is it
intuitively hard uh to do this with less
than n queries so what's the natural
algorithm you pick one vertex you go
over the edges to see if there's another
non-dummy neighbor or not so that's
going to take omega in time
um yeah so one caveat is that here you
can actually quickly in the in digestive
list model you can quickly in login time
figure out the degree of a Vertex so
here you can quickly say that these
verses have decree that's smaller by one
than the vertices here so you can
actually distinguish these two graphs
pretty fast but this is easy to fix you
just add two stars all the vertices will
have the same decrease in the two graphs
except for these two vertices
and because there's just two vertices
finding one of them also requires
creating Omega and vertices so this is
the lower this is the whole lower bound
um
that proves any constant approximation
Omega and time for it is needed Okay so
essentially the this proof what it does
is that every vertex it says that every
vertex has just one important Edge and
has a large linear in N degree
just to see at least one important edge
of just one vertex you're going to have
to spend Omega in time so that that's
the sense of the lower bound
um so what what I'll talk about now is
proving super linear in and lower bounds
so we want n to one plus Epsilon yeah
what is the degree of a Vertex before
often reading this stuff
so before I added the star these verses
would have degree Epsilon and only to
the dummy vertices
and these would have Epsilon and plus
one
the reason I ask is because you can
basically
detect the the woods of those Styles but
it will take you to learn time yeah it
will take you oh my God and time exactly
so
right
um okay good question
um yeah so we want to prove super linear
and lower bounds and the problem with
super linear and lower bands that you
cannot just have one important Edge per
vertex that you cannot discover because
you can just pick one vertex maybe at
random
just query all of its edges that takes
order and time so you will see some
important edges but the the pro the the
the construction should basically say
that even though you will see these
important edges you cannot figure out
that they're important so that's going
to be the
um
what you'll have to do okay so what do
we get
so this is ethereum we proved with
Muhammad and aviad at this past stock so
we showed that for any fixed positive
Epsilon any better than two-thirds
approximation of the size of the maximum
matching in the adjacency of this model
requires n to the 1.2 time so this is
super linear in hand
so just uh put together the lower bounds
and the upper bounds so these were the
upper bounds that we knew the partners
run lower band basically rules out any
um better than end time algorithm for
any constant approximation here we rule
out algorithms in these in this region
we basically said any better than
two-thirds approximation
would have to spend more than n to the
1.2 time okay and as you see there are a
lot of
um regions where the answer is unsure
for example can we get all the way up to
two-thirds in order and time there are a
lot of nice open questions to think
about
um okay any questions about the
statement of the result
so this is what I what I spend uh most
of the time right okay
so I start by defining the
um input distribution what is uh the
distribution of the graph that is hard
to provided better than two-thirds
approximation on
so so this is going to be the
construction
um
so we will still have Epsilon and dummy
versus they played exactly the same role
they want we want to make the graph
dense and we do not want to change its
matching so these dummy varices do
exactly that and then this is what
happens in the chord this is now more
complicated than just having either a
matching or nothing okay so what's going
on here we have three types of vertices
the S varices
the B vertices and the a vertices okay
and in case it's not clear
there's also a
graph of degree D between a and b and a
graph of D between A and B here
okay
um so so what's
um
so what's the distribution like so we
have again two types of uh graphs graphs
on which the matching is large graph
some which the matching is small and any
better than two-thirds approximation
should should distinguish two uh so this
is the no case where the matching is
small
um so what what is it like so we have
um a matching from the S varices to B
vertices and when you look at the core
the degrees of the verse is in s is
always going to be one
um and the reason we chose s is because
we call them Singleton vertices so
Singleton versus only have degree one
and they have to be in the matching so
it's it's generally you can prove that
if you want to find the maximum matching
any degree one vertices you're just
going to have to match it to its
neighborhood without lots of generality
okay so these degree one vertices will
be adjacent to B through our matching
um I have degree one in the core they're
still connected to the dummy vertices
um okay and then
um the the averages are only adjacent to
B so if you look at the matching of the
core uh if you match s to b the averages
will be left unmatched okay so the core
the optimal matching in the core is just
matching s versus to B verses and
leaving all the a vertices are matched
and now in the yes case what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add a matching
between the averages
um so so one case the matching is 1.5
times the matching in the no case
um
and anybody around two thirds
approximation should be able to
distinguish the two distributions
so this is so just just one comment this
is a wrong distribution but it provides
the right intuition about a final
distribution so we're going to have to
change something
um slightly and that's exactly the size
of a and b and and yeah but but but for
now suppose that A and B are of the same
test but the basic question in this
picture why you need these dummy tea
vertices again
um so
okay I I I'll answer you in a minute
um so the answer is the following
um so first of all before before
um telling you that
um
I'm gonna once I construct this graph
I'm gonna assign random IDs to the
vertices right so I want to basically
hide which of these sets a Vertex
belongs to but actually I give away
versus in T and verses in s
so I'm gonna tell you these verses are
in s
these verses are the dummy varices what
I'm not going to tell you is
um the verses in the
Union of A and B I'm not going to tell
you if they're A or B so you're going to
have to figure that out yourself
okay
so so now suppose that you take one
vertex in either A or B and you want to
verify whether it's in a or b so what's
a naive algorithm
you want to have to basically go through
the neighbors and see if it has a
neighboring s or not that's the only
difference between a and b
so what do you do you go over the
Neighbors in the adjacent list of that
vertex until hitting an S vertex and
I've given you for free yes versus so
once you see an asteroid text you're
done you know that that is a nest vertex
um so you can spend Omega Epsilon and
time because all the degrees are still
Epsilon and at least because of the
dummy vertices so once you go through
the adjacency list it takes Epsilon and
queries to actually hit that s vertex
and in case I forgot to mention I'm also
going to randomly permute the adjacency
lists everyone is connected to the dummy
or all verses in the core will always be
adjacent to all verses all dummy verses
so
then it's not a bipartite graph anymore
uh you can make it biparton easily just
the picture would be a little bit okay
yeah but you can easily just yeah the
the statement holds also for by
paragraphs
okay
um yeah so naively if you wanna
basically check if a Vertex is an a
Vertex or a B vertex you're going to
have to spend Omega in time
um
but that's not going to be enough to to
distinguish yes and no we're gonna
actually have to
uh figure out if there are any AA edges
so the difference between yes and no
remember that it was inclusion of this a
a matching so we're going to have to
basically check if there is an AA
matching in the graph or not okay
um
so so what's the naive algorithm so the
naive algorithm is I start with a vertex
in a I can find one in order and time I
just pick a random vertex from a union B
with quality half is in a in order and
time I check this if it's not I sample
again so that that's that's easy so I
start with the vertex in a
and then
I go over all of its neighbors some of
the neighbors go to the dummy set
I ignore those so there are the other
neighbors
that
so what happens is in the yes case all
but one of them are in B and that one is
an A in no case all of them go to B
so I have D neighbors either there's one
a Vertex among them where there's no a
Vertex among them are gonna have to
distinguish the two so the naive
algorithm would run this check
um on all of these D neighbors you check
if it's a or b so what's the total
running time n times d
and D is the degree of this by paragraph
and think of it as N2 Epsilon or n to
the point two for now I'll tell you why
you cannot set it to be so high but for
now think of it as N2 Epsilon so what
this would
tell you is that the naive algorithm
actually takes super linear in and time
to distinguish yes and no distributions
how do you know whether whether it lands
an A and B because like you still need
to check whether the vertex on the other
side is
exactly that that's what the naive
algorithm does so you start from a
um and you go over all of the D
neighbors maybe one of them goes to a
the rest go to B so in all of those
neighbors you run the CH the the test
whether it's an A or B so on all of them
you you're going to spend Omega and time
and because of the neighbors you're
gonna in total spend ND time which is
super linear
so
the first time we actually noticed maybe
it's possible to prove a superlinear
lower bound and we thought about it for
a little bit and then we actually know
this that there is a very fast algorithm
for this yeah yeah I haven't seen a
question that the neighbors that
yeah
what you I mean you basically
if you know the time but for each of
them you basically spend cost of time
yeah so I'm gonna give you the list of
all the vertices in T and you can just
quickly check yeah so so for those in
constant time you just rule them out
you're only gonna have to decide on the
remaining D neighbors whether they are
in a or b
yeah
um okay so yeah so intuitively it seems
that the knife algorithm is the best one
can do
um so yeah so we want to see if there's
an AAA Edge or not
um probably have to just check all the
neighbors and take super linear and time
but there is a probably a little bit
weirder than counterintuitive algorithm
that actually solves this instance in
order end time Singleton's identify me
uh
Singletons
and then your time you can use The
Singletons to find out all of them right
no no single tones are actually
um also connected to the dummy vertices
so for Singletons if you want to find
their neighbors you're going to have to
spend n time
so you can spend time and that gives it
just one B birthday so that's not
um what you can do yeah can you see the
degrees of the vertex in consonants or
do you need to look at the whole list so
suppose yeah so you can just buy new
research on the adjacent list
you're just given the degree of any
vertex that you want
right so yeah so so that was actually a
great question because in the yes case
and in no case the degrees of the
averages are different but that that's
that's not hard to hard hard to hide so
you can use similar tricks as in
including stars or maybe like I think
um them to be or something and yeah so
so let's let's not use the decrease
that's a good point so in the
distribution that I mentioned you can
actually use the degrees and distinguish
the two very fast but yeah so I still
have so many questions if you're in the
in me so all birds all neighbors of vrna
and all neighbors of the a with one RnB
right so I don't see why you need to
test more than like a constant number of
visitors edges to DNA to decide which
one you're in
um so every a Vertex has just one
neighbor in a if any yes yes either
nothing or one and there are D choices
okay so this is your essentially you
want to find it if that exists yes
so you're gonna have to actually go
through this can you if you just find
two vertices in a with probability one
over n they'll have an edge between them
yes so you can figure out in order and
time that
so you're gonna have to sample maybe n
payers
and finding any vertex requires end time
itself so that would aggregate to N
squared
so the the trick is to use random works
um so this is how you can
um solve this input distribution order
and time
and the reason I want to mention this is
because improving lower bounds you're
going to have to be careful about these
kind of thingy algorithms when you
design algorithms random works that go
so long are just rarely useful
for for matchings but somehow for this
input distribution we see how it can be
used so so the random walk algorithm
starts with a vertex in a
um so we pick a vertex in a again this
can be done in order and time so that's
that's okay
and then what we do is we want to pick a
random neighbor in b
okay Mark that the neighbors of a in B
I'm gonna pick one random and basically
random work on the on the core vertices
okay so how long does it take for for an
a vertex
to discover a random neighbor in B so
there are the degrees n
uh Atmos n actually Epsilon n plus d
this order the degree of this vertex is
order n and D of them go to B so start
querying the adjacency list at random
and in N over D time you're gonna hit
one vertex in b
so just to clarify I I want to make sure
that the random walk from a does not
step on the dummy version so I just want
to make sure that it goes to B okay and
I'm saying that this this one step can
be done in N over D time
um and then I continue the random work
um so from B it goes back to a
from a again it goes back to B because
every step takes n over D time I can
afford to do this for order uh these
steps
you go over all the neighbors until
finding an S vertex and that takes anti
so I'm not testing if it's a b Vertex or
a Vertex on along the random work
um oh so so I'm giving the given the
dummy versus so once I step on the dummy
vertex I ignore it
yeah and if I don't step on a dummy
vertex
um it's got to be an a a b vertex this
random work May visit vertices of AHS
unlikely right this is
yeah so so basically in the no case you
go from A to B and from B to a
in the yes case there is a small chance
that you actually go through the aah
Edge okay so if I repeat this for
um these steps
overall the running time is order n
every step takes n over D there are
these steps and if I do this with an
even number of steps to say 2D in the no
case I start from a every two steps I go
back to a so I'm definitely going to be
in a after these 2D steps
but in the new case
um every step that you're in a there's a
property one over a d that you actually
go through the a edge and there's a
statistically significant probability
that you actually exactly go through on
aah exactly once
um if if you have a 2d step random walk
and in this case if you start from from
a you go to b a uh and from a to a so
the parity changes and because you do
this once you'll end up in um actually B
so in the yes case there's a constant
property that you end up in B in the no
case you're always going to be in a and
this is enough to distinguish the two
cases in order end time overall okay so
the takeaway yeah
so so you just gonna on the end on the
end point of the around the work you're
just gonna run the test if it's a
European that takes enzyme
you're gonna go over all of the doesn't
matter that you're in uh the top view or
the bottom B so if you're in B that's
definitely going to be a yes case
so you do it fixed
two-day work
and then check at the end you just check
what the last uh vertex is
and it's already you'll only switch once
yeah
exactly exactly
exactly right so so this takes order and
time overall
um and so so basically the takeaway is
that these long query paths can actually
be helpful
okay so so for some maybe artificial
algorithm but still the lower bound
should should be careful about about
these kind of algorithms but I guess you
also have to be careful about maybe like
hitting a three time I mean like the
fact that you hit it exactly once you're
just saying there's a constant
probability yeah
yeah yeah so so this only works if you
go through a exactly once
um but there's a constant property you
can repeat this multiple times and if
any one of them
um does this and you're gonna
for sure I know that this is a this is a
yes
okay so so how
First Step because yeah you only check
the first and the last verses of the
path not the verses in in between
Focus otherwise you have a path of
length D you cannot spend n time for
each or that would be super linear
yeah but if you add the edges to make a
and b have the same degrees don't you
have
like you have the same chance of
crossing over yeah that's actually yeah
that's true and that's also kind of the
fix that we have to this this dish so
the fix is is as follows
um
so so what was nice about the random
work algorithm what was the crucial
property that the random walk algorithm
used it was that every time that you're
in B you go back to a
um and it's only possible to go back uh
from a to a not from B to B okay so
every time you're in B you go to a from
a most likely you go to B but there's a
slight chance that you stay in a
so you want to change this
so in the in the fixed distribution
we're gonna add so so the degrees from A
to B is still D I think of D again as
enter Epsilon or n to point two
um and
from B to a
we're going to have one minus Epsilon D
edges so the degrees from B to a is now
slightly less
um
and
also we're going to have Epsilon D edges
from B to B
well now
in the walk algorithm if you're in a
you're still most likely going to be
this is just part one over D that you
stay in a
but if you're in B there's a probability
Epsilon relatively large probability
that you stay in so from B you go to B
okay so this is why
um so every step there's a constant
property that you change parity no
matter if you're in the S case or in the
no case
um oh and also let me just finalize
finish the the description of the the
distribution so in the yes case we're
going to add all edges between a and
just to fix the degree uh problem I'm
gonna also add edges between B one
special matching
so know that all the degrees of the
vertices in B and all the degrees in a
are going to be
um
D plus one
such a lot no D plus one exactly all the
verses in A and B have exactly the same
degrees outside the core plus the
Epsilon number yeah that's outside the
core yeah yeah inside the core yeah
um okay and in no case I don't want to
have a matching between the averages
but this is going to be the matching
that they have still the the largest
matching in this core in the no case is
just to match s to be and so the
matching is still going to be much
smaller okay so this is the fix to the
distribution and this is in fact the
Distribution on which we are able to
prove that any algorithm has to spend
um and to the 1.2 time how much time do
you have
between 10 and
so I was yeah I was a bit slow I guess
but it's okay
um so so let's now try to see how we can
formalize this lower amount
so there are four steps uh the first
step is is this important insight
that if you start that any algorithm
that you take
um and
craze less than n to the 1.2 entries
um overall in the whole graph will not
be able to see any cycle in the core and
this end to the 1.2
um and just just one emphasize that the
that the degree D here is going to be n
to the point two um and the reason
exactly that we cannot set it to be
higher
um is because we want to get this
property that there is no cycle in the
core okay so we want to make sure that
any algorithm that starts querying the
graph cannot see any cycle in the core
okay
and we get this so long as the number of
queries
um solang as D is smaller than n to the
point two
um and uh yeah and this is the reason
that that we get a lower Runner into the
1.2 basically
okay and this is also the crucial
difficulty in proving any better lower
bounds um for example say you want to
even relax the approximation to say 0.99
can you prove near quadratic lower bound
this is this is what we don't know how
to do
inside the the core you will see cycles
and you're going to have to handle those
okay and the proof of this you can just
convince yourself in two minutes if you
think about this so basically the
um
any algorithm any
um query
results in an edge in the core with
probability D Over N most of them go to
the dummy vertices so in total we're
gonna see the probability of seeing an
edge in the core for every query is n to
the minus 0.8
um the total number of edges that we
discover in the core is the total of
queries times the probability that each
one lands in core and that's Q times n
to the minus Point
um eight Q is n to the 1.2 so this is n
to the point four edges
um we have n to the point four edges the
12 number of pairs of vertices is n to
the point eight
and just for any pair the probability
that it's actually an edge in the core a
source model that you can do unimp it's
just all I'm saying is that this is a
very simple argument to show that you
won't see a cycle inside the core so
some of them just that you're adding for
example from B to B yeah
uh to make sure that the degrees are the
same yeah cannot you and then you are
basically risking closing Cycles then
you're proving that you're not but
currently you were sorted by for example
adding edges to T in a more careful way
so that your
um
like currently you're saying that the
vertices in NPR connected to the in the
same yeah
that will give you the same effect so
like I want to give away the dummy
versus for free at the beginning so the
degrees to the dummy version is actually
oh so you're saying that for for fixing
the degrees
yeah yeah maybe maybe
but still we're gonna have to add DB
edges
because you wanna because the random
walk algorithm it's important to jump to
to change the parity even in no case
yeah good point okay
can I assume that the queries are
deterministic but then you like Shuffle
the edges around them yeah yeah so so
I'm just gonna prove the lower amount
for deterministic algorithms now because
this is a distribution or input and then
you apply your osme max yeah yeah
so this is it yeah so so I'm basically
I've shuffled the I just list I assume
that if you want to query a new uh
neighbor it's going to be this the next
one that you can assume
this exactly the reason why we have one
point two yeah yeah
um
okay so the second step is okay now that
we don't see any cycle in the core what
we have really is a is a forest
um actually technically we get a
stronger one it's going to be a rooted
Forest the rooted uh if you carefully uh
make the edges directed in the order of
which vertex created that edge
um but yeah but but that doesn't matter
so so we're gonna basically see a tree
um and so we start with the vertex it's
going to be either an a Vertex or a B
vertex this is hidden from us and then
I'm gonna be able to say okay so give me
a new neighbor of this vertex
um most likely it's going to be a b
vertex but there's a slight chances
actually an a vertex and we won't see
these labels so we we keep querying
but how can we learn
um anything about the graph if we don't
see these labels the only thing that we
see is whether we've seen an S vertex
whether we've seen any of those
Singleton vertices so basically I can
view the algorithm
um any algorithm for sublinear matching
in that distribution as an algorithm
that solves this problem on trees so
basically you have a hidden label on the
vertices that determines the probability
of transitioning to the uh to different
types so from a you'll always go to B
from B there's a Epsilon property that
you go to B one myself somebody that you
go go to a and there's a slight
um uh one over D chance that you
actually go from B to S so we will see
these s varices but not the the so
basically this is what the algorithm
queries so once you see an S vertex
you'll for sure know that the neighbor
must be a b vertex
so you get some information about the
tree but still there could be multiple
um realizations
um of what you what you've seen okay so
the question now is is there an
efficient process
that solves this tree uh this problem on
trees
um and that that's that's what we prove
uh is impossible with less than uh
what is the problem you are trying to
solve on Truth okay yeah
uh right so
so there so the tree you have two
distribution the yes distribution there
is a slight chance that from an a Vertex
you go to an a vertex
there is the no distribution where
there's never going to be any AAA you
never jump from a to a okay
so what can we do so so we start with a
root it is either a or b you don't know
so every time the algorithm can say Okay
reveal a new child for this specific
vertex and it's going to be drawn
according to the uh to the type of that
word the distribution depends on the
type of that vertex
um so you're gonna the question is how
many
um uh how many times do you have to
reveal children to actually uh uh
distinguish the two this distributions
from one another
so there's just one slight difference
that from a there is a chance that you
go to to another paper
so
we want to prove that both in the yes
case so if we want to prove that for any
outcome t
um of this tree if we prove that the
property that it's drawn from the yes
distribution is exactly the same as the
property that's drawn from the node
distribution we're done we're going to
say okay there's no algorithm that can
distinguish them
but this is not true unfortunately
um so to consider this tree this vertex
has D plus one neighbors this word and
none of them is an S vertex so this is
this has to be an a vertex
same for this this is
um scene D plus d plus one neighbors
none of them is s so both of these have
to be a you've just found an AA Edge so
if you somehow discover this tree
you would immediately get that you're in
the yes distribution
so what we're going to argue is that
um
what does it have to be an AAA this this
has to be a this also has to be a
because the we've queried all of the
neighbors and have not seen an S
neighbor
B versus have a nest neighbor for sure
averages do not have any s neighbors so
if you see all the neighbors and there's
no s between them it it has to be yeah
it has to be a
right so so what we prove at the end is
okay there are really just small trees
that if you happen to see them they're
going to convince you that you're in the
yes distribution but we're gonna say
that okay so for the likely trees that
an algorithm discovers
um this property is going to be the same
so the probability that you end up with
a tree that you can
um distinguish the two
um fast is so small that that yeah it's
not gonna happen
and so the the third step that I think
is uh kind of nice
um and so the the
to me it feels like the the core of the
proof is to use correlation Decay um so
yes I want to uh I don't want to spend
too much time on this because I don't
have
um too much time
um but basically so what we prove is
um morally it's the the following
that take a vertex
if you've not created many many vertices
close to it right so just look at for
example the radius polylog and below
this vertex if the total number of
vertices that you've revealed within
that range
is not too large
specifically it's smaller than D okay
you've not basically queried all the
neighbors of any vertex that's close to
this vertex what we prove is that the
probability that you see this tree is
the same no matter what the label of
that root is right so either you query a
lot of vertices close to the vertex
um and that's going to give you a lot of
information about the label of that
vertex
or if you do not basically I want to
argue that you won't know anything about
the label of that vertex okay so so this
can be formalized
um a little bit uh yeah this game is
stated a little bit more formally but
but morally what you basically say is
that either you make a lot of queries
close to a vertex
um or else you won't know anything about
the label of the vertex okay so it's
going to be a or b
um anyone know anything about it and
this solves even if you condition on
things about the vertex but I'm not
going to talk about that okay
so how is this useful
um so using this correlation Decay Lemma
I will prove this via correlation decay
um we get that if you have an AA Edge UV
that the algorithm queries uh at some
point the algorithm will seek aahs
that's inevitable we're going to have to
prove that Diagon won't notice that this
was an aah Edge so so how do we argue
this
we see that
um
yeah so so if if less than if if the
total number of queries close to one
endpoint of this aash is much smaller
than d right so we have not made a lot
of queries close to at least one of the
endpoints of this aash
so from the perspective of the algorithm
um this this is uh the algorithm won't
know that this is an a Vertex right so
basically even knowing that one endpoint
is a so basically we have this a a edge
so suppose that I even tell you that
this is
um an a vertex
if you've created a small number of
verses around this other vertex
you will most likely think that this is
a b word because you know this is a most
averages most of neighbors of a go to B
and this won't give you any information
any indication that this is a
neighborhood so from the perspective of
the algorithm you think that's actually
this is an most likely you think this is
an A B Edge
so if you're going to want to know where
to concentrate the queries so a lot of
the queries will be based and you won't
be able to
essentially there won't be an AAA Edge
where you've queried a lot of vertices
close to both endpoints okay so that's
that's I guess as as far as I can
cool okay just uh so I'm going to skip
this part so we have a follow-up work
um that proves a new lower and
performance of some approximations for
low degree graphs
um yeah I'm not going to talk about this
but basically just to conclude
um these are the algorithms we know for
the sub matching problem
um these are the lower bounds there are
a lot of nice questions
um two of my favorites are can we get
better than half approximation still in
order and poly login time
um and the second one is for one minus
Epsilon approximations
QB achieve an algorithm running in N to
the 1.99 time so this algorithm it runs
in N to the two minus Epsilon time where
this Epsilon depends on the
approximation
um
I'm asking if is it possible to get rid
of this Epsilon in the exponent maybe
you can multiply one exponential in one
over Epsilon to n 2.1 into 1.99 yeah
such an algorithm would be really cool
okay
um
[Applause]
so we have time for one big question
maybe Julian you can walk up
so I'm not sure if I understood
correctly but the three model technique
doesn't that sound very very general
right I have the feeling it didn't have
anything to do with with matching then
anymore and as soon as you can yeah it's
all about the distribution exactly yeah
so so you just specify what the three
model what the distribution of going
from A to B and from B to a is and that
comes from the construction for
matchings the rest of it is just not
this is just about it so this could
potentially be a very general tool for
simulator
thanks cool
thank you again
[Applause]
yeah now we have one of our
co-organizers give a talk uh Julian Sean
from MIT is an assistant professor at
MIT and he'll tell us about the batch
Bearer
parallel batch Dynamic K code
okay great uh thanks a lot so
I'm a bit under whether I'm gonna keep
my mask on if anyone wants to put on
their mask or leave I won't be offended
okay so uh today I'm going to talk about
our work on Parallel batch Dynamic uh
k-core decomposition this is Joint work
with Juan con Leo Jessica
you've heard a little bit about this
work in Quan Quan's talk earlier in this
Workshop but I'll provide some more